[Music]  Halloween I think was I think a lot of  people had fun  yeah people here had fun but I got to  tell you I personally I'm glad it's over  I'm glad it's over yeah and I'll tell  you why yesterday  Andy was hiding around the office and  then jumping out and scaring people the  best now you're a grown man  great yeah yeah so he hides he jumps out  and scares people he does it all day  worst of all this year I think the first  year he taped it yeah he taped but he  was isn't this right Andy yeah and I man  I got la Bamba fantastic this is the one  I want to show you watch this  now naturally yeah some of you are  probably wondering how could the bombuh  be in the band tonight  if Andy murdered him yesterday there's a  very simple explanation  [Applause]  why am i wet he's made of fun  [Applause]  [Music]  that is such a stupid idea  [Laughter]